Piensa en edificios, calles,
rascacielos y taxis ruidosos.
Cuando yo pienso en las ciudades,
pienso en la gente.
Principalmente, las ciudades tienen que ver con la gente:
adónde va
y dónde se reúne
está en la esencia de lo que hace que una ciudad funcione.
Así que, aún más importantes que los edificios
son los espacios públicos entre ellos.
Hoy en día, algunos de los cambios más transformadores de las ciudades
se dan en los espacios públicos.
Por eso creo que los espacios públicos alegres y agradables
son esenciales para planificar una gran ciudad.
Son los que le dan vida.
Pero ¿qué hace que un espacio público funcione?
¿Qué hace que ciertos espacios públicos
atraigan a la gente y que otros la alejen?
Pensé que si conseguía contestar esas preguntas,
podría hacer una gran contribución a mi ciudad.
Una de las cosas más confusas sobre mí
es que soy conductista de animales,
pero no uso estas habilidades para analizar el comportamiento animal,
sino para estudiar cómo la gente utiliza
los espacios públicos de las ciudades.
Uno de los primeros lugares que analicé
fue un parquecito diminuto llamado Paley Park,
en el medio de Manhattan.
Este lugarcito se convirtió en un pequeño fenómeno.
Cómo causó tan profundo impacto en los neoyorquinos
fue lo que me causó a mí una profunda impresión.
Estudié este parque muy al comienzo de mi carrera
porque resulta que fue mi padrastro quien lo construyó.
Así descubrí que los lugares como Paley Park
no aparecen por accidente.
Vi con mis propios ojos que requerían
una gran dedicación y una gran atención a los detalles.
Pero ¿qué hizo que este lugar
fuese especial y atrajera a la gente?
Me sentaba en el parque a observar atentamente.
Lo primero, entre otras cosas,
eran las cómodas sillas móviles.
La gente llegaba, elegía su asiento,
lo movía un poco y se quedaban un rato.
Curiosamente, estas personas atraían a otras
e irónicamente, yo me sentía más tranquila
si había gente cerca.
Estaba lleno de vegetación.
Ofrecía lo que los neoyorquinos anhelan:
comodidad y espacios verdes.
Pero mi pregunta era:
¿por qué no hay más lugares con espacios verdes y asientos
en medio de la ciudad
donde no te sientas solo o como un intruso?
Desafortunadamente, no era así
como se diseñaban las ciudades.
Aquí tienen una imagen familiar.
Así se han diseñado las plazas por generaciones.
Tienen ese aspecto elegante y espartano
que solemos asociar a la arquitectura moderna,
pero no sorprende que la gente evite lugares como estos.
No solo se ven desolados:
sino que dan una sensación total de peligro.
Quiero decir, ¿dónde se sentaría uno aquí?
¿Qué haría?
Pero a los arquitectos les encantan.
Son pedestales para sus creaciones.
Podrían tolerar una o dos estatuas, pero no mucho más.
Son ideales para los promotores inmobiliarios.
Nada que regar, nada que mantener,
y no habrá gente indeseable por quien preocuparse.
Pero ¿no creen que es un desperdicio?
Para mí, volverme planificadora urbana
significaba poder verdaderamente cambiar
la ciudad que amaba y en la que vivía.
Quería ser capaz de crear lugares
que despertasen el sentimiento de Paley Park
e impedir que promotores inmobiliarios construyesen plazas inhóspitas como esta.
Pero a lo largo de los años, he aprendido lo difícil que es
crear espacios públicos que funcionen, valiosos y agradables para la gente.
Como aprendí de mi padrastro, desde luego, no aparecen por accidente.
Sobre todo en una ciudad como Nueva York,
donde, para empezar, hay que pelear por los espacios públicos
y, luego, para que estos tengan éxito,
alguien debe pensar mucho en cada detalle.
Los espacios abiertos en las ciudades son oportunidades.
Sí, oportunidades para la inversión comercial,
pero también para el bien común de la ciudad.
Pero esos dos propósitos a menudo no van de la mano
y ahí está el problema.
Mi primera oportunidad para luchar
por un gran espacio público abierto fue a principios de los años 80,
cuando dirigía a un equipo de planificadores
en un enorme relleno llamado Battery Park City,
en el bajo Manhattan, sobre el río Hudson.
Este páramo arenoso llevaba estéril más de 10 años,
y nos dijeron que, si no encontrábamos un promotor,
en 6 meses, iría a la quiebra.
Entonces tuvimos una idea innovadora, casi una locura.
En lugar de construir un parque como complemento al desarrollo futuro,
¿por qué no invertir la ecuación y hacer, primero, un espacio público abierto
pequeño, pero de gran calidad, y ver si eso marcaba la diferencia?
Solo teníamos dinero para construir una parte de dos cuadras
de lo que luego sería una costanera de 1,5 km,
así que, lo que construyésemos tenía que ser perfecto.
Para asegurarme, insistí en que hiciéramos
una modelo a escala real, en madera, de la barandilla y el rompeolas.
Y cuando me senté en ese banco de prueba,
con la arena aún arremolinándose alrededor mío,
la barandilla quedaba justo a la altura de la vista,
tapando el paisaje y arruinando la vista del río.
¿Ven? Los detalles sí hacen la diferencia.
Pero el diseño no se trata solo del aspecto de las cosas;
trata también de cómo nos sentimos en ese asiento, en ese lugar.
Creo que un diseño exitoso siempre depende
de la experiencia personal.
En esta imagen, todo parece terminado,
pero ese borde de granito, esas luces,
el respaldo de ese banco,
los árboles plantados
y los distintos lugares para sentarse,
fueron todos pequeñas batallas que convirtieron este proyecto
en un lugar en el que la gente quisiera estar.
Tras 20 años, resultó ser una lección muy valiosa,
puesto que Michael Bloomberg me pidió ser su Comisionada de Planificación
y me encargó de dar forma a toda la ciudad de Nueva York.
Ese mismo día me dijo
que se esperaba que Nueva York creciese de 8 a 9 millones de personas.
Y me preguntó:
"¿Dónde vas a meter a ese millón extra de neoyorquinos?
Yo no tenía ni idea.
Uds. saben que, para Nueva York, es importante atraer a inmigrantes,
así que nos entusiasmaba la perspectiva de crecimiento,
pero, sinceramente, ¿dónde íbamos a construir
en una ciudad ya edificada hasta los límites
y rodeada de agua?
¿Cómo íbamos a encontrar viviendas para tantos nuevos neoyorquinos?
Y si no podíamos expandirnos, lo cual quizás fuese bueno,
¿dónde colocaríamos las nuevas viviendas?
¿Y qué pasaría con los autos? La ciudad no soportaría más autos.
¿Qué íbamos a hacer?
Si no podíamos expandirnos, tendríamos que elevarnos.
Y si nos elevábamos, tendríamos que hacerlo en lugares
donde no se necesitase tener auto.
Eso implicaba usar uno de nuestros principales recursos:
el sistema de transporte.
Nunca habíamos pensado en cómo sacarle el mayor provecho.
Aquí estaba la respuesta a nuestro problema.
Pensamos que, si canalizábamos y redirigíamos las nuevas construcciones
en torno al transporte,
podríamos manejar el aumento de población.
Este era el plan, lo que de verdad había que hacer:
Necesitábamos modificar las zonas urbanas, porque la división en zonas
es la herramienta regulatoria del planificador urbano.
Era, básicamente, reestrucurar toda la ciudad,
centrándonos en dónde podían ir los nuevos desarrollos,
y prohibiendo cualquier tipo de construcción
en los barrios suburbanos orientados al transporte en auto.
Era una idea increíblemente ambiciosa.
Ambiciosa, porque las comunidades
debían aprobar esos planes.
¿Cómo iba a conseguirlo?
Escuchando. Así que empecé a escuchar.
Dediqué miles de horas a escuchar,
solo para generar confianza.
Los vecinos se dan cuenta si entiendes o no su barrio.
No es algo que se pueda fingir.
Empecé a caminar.
No se imaginan cuántas cuadras caminé,
en veranos sofocantes, en inviernos helados, año tras año,
solo para poder entender el ADN de cada barrio
y saber cómo se vivía en cada calle.
Me convertí en una experta obsesionada con las zonas urbanas,
tratando de ver cómo esta división por zonas
podía dar respuesta a los intereses de la comunidad.
Poco a poco, barrio a barrio, cuadra a cuadra,
empezamos a establecer límites de altura para que toda construcción nueva
fuese predecible y estuviese cerca del transporte.
Durante el transcurso de 12 años,
logramos rediseñar 124 barrios,
el 40% de la ciudad;
12 500 manzanas,
para que hoy, el 90% de los edificios nuevos de Nueva York
esté a menos de 10 minutos a pie del metro.
En otras palabras, nadie en esos nuevos edificios
necesita tener un auto.
Esa reestrucuración de las zonas fue agotadora y enervante pero importante,
aunque nunca fue mi objetivo.
La regulación de zonas no se ve ni se siente.
Mi objetivo fue siempre crear espacios públicos fabulosos.
Estaba decidida a crear,
en aquellas zonas en las que habíamos planificado un gran desarrollo,
lugares que marcasen una diferencia en la vida de la gente.
Aquí ven lo que eran 3 km de costa abandonada y deteriorada
en los barrios de Greenpoint y Williamsburg en Brooklyn.
Imposible llegar ahí e imposible utilizarlos.
La urbanización en esta zona era enorme,
así que sentía la obligación de crear parques magníficos en esta ribera.
Dediqué una cantidad increíble de tiempo a cada cm2 de esos planos.
Quería asegurarme de que hubiese
caminos con árboles desde la parte alta hasta el agua,
que hubiese árboles y plantas por todas partes,
y, por supuesto, muchísimos lugares para sentarse.
Sinceramente, no sabía cómo iba a resultar.
Debía tener fe.
En esos planos puse todo lo que había estudiado y aprendido.
Llegó el momento de la inauguración, y he de decir que fue increíble.
La gente venía de toda la ciudad para estar en estos parques.
Sé que cambiaron la vida de los que viven en la zona,
y que también cambiaron la imagen que los neoyorquinos
tenían de su ciudad.
A veces voy y miro a la gente subir a ese pequeño ferry
que ahora conecta los distritos,
y no sé explicar por qué, pero me conmueve enormemente
que la gente lo use ahora como si siempre hubiese estado ahí.
Este es un parque nuevo en el bajo Manhattan.
La costa del bajo Manhattan
era un desastre antes del 11 de septiembre.
Wall Street estaba prácticamente bloqueada por tierra,
porque nadie podía acercarse,
Y después del 11 de septiembre, la ciudad tenía muy poco control.
Pero pensé que si íbamos
a la Lower Manhattan Development Corporation
y conseguíamos dinero para recuperar esos 3 km de ribera deteriorada,
podría tener un gran efecto en la reconstrucción del bajo Manhattan.
Y así fue.
El bajo Manhattan por fin tiene una costanera pública
en sus tres frentes.
Realmente adoro este parque.
Ahora las barandillas deben ser más altas,
así que pusimos unas banquetas tipo bar en todo el borde
y te puedes acercar tanto al agua que casi estás sobre ella.
Y miren cómo la barandilla ensanchada y achatada
permite dejar ahí tu almuerzo o tu portátil.
Me encanta cuando la gente va allí, eleva la mirada y piensa:
"¡Ah, allí está Brooklyn! ¡Está tan cerca!"
¿Cuál es el truco?
¿Cómo conviertes un parque en un lugar donde la gente quiere estar?
Bueno, depende de ti.
No como planificador urbano, sino como ciudadano.
No recurres a tus habilidades como diseñador,
sino lo piensas como ser humano.
Quiero decir, ¿te gustaría ir ahí?
¿Querrías quedarte?
¿Tienes una buena vista del parque? ¿y desde allí?
¿Hay más personas?
¿Tiene espacios verdes y parece agradable?
¿Puedes encontrar tu propio asiento?
Ahora, por toda la ciudad de Nueva York,
hay lugares en los que puedes encontrar tu propio asiento.
Donde había estacionamientos, ahora hay cafeterías.
Donde pasaba el tráfico de Broadway, ahora hay mesas y sillas.
Donde hace 12 años no estaban permitidos los cafés en las aceras,
ahora están por todas partes.
Pero recuperar estos espacios para el uso público no fue sencillo
y es aún más difícil mantenerlos así.
Ahora les contaré una historia
sobre un parque nada normal llamado High Line.
High Line era un ferrocarril elevado.
(Aplausos)
High Line era un ferrocarril elevado
que pasaba por tres barrios de West Side Manhattan.
Cuando el tren dejó de funcionar, se convirtió en un paisaje silvestre,
algo así como un jardín en el cielo.
Y cuando lo vi por primera vez, cuando subí a ese viejo viaducto,
me enamoré como te enamoras de una persona, sinceramente.
Entonces, cuando fui nombrada,
salvar las dos primeras partes de High Line de la demolición
se convirtió en mi prioridad absoluta y en mi proyecto más importante.
Sabía que si pasaba un solo día
en que no me preocupase por High Line, lo demolerían.
High Line, ahora muy conocido
y extraordinariamente popular,
es el espacio público más disputado de la ciudad.
Puede que vean un hermoso parque, pero no todos lo ven así.
Sí, es cierto, los intereses comerciales
siempre pelearán contra los espacios públicos.
Uds. pueden pensar:
"¿No es maravilloso que más de 4 millones de personas
Pero un constructor ve solo una cosa: clientes.
"¿Por qué no quitar esas plantas y poner tiendas por todo High Line?
¿No sería estupendo? ¿No traería más dinero a la ciudad?"
¡Pues no! No sería estupendo.
Sería un centro comercial, no un parque.
(Aplausos)
¿Y saben qué? Podría representar más dinero para la ciudad,
pero la ciudad ha de pensar a largo plazo, pensar en el bien común.
Hace poco, la última parte de High Line, la tercera parte, la parte final,
se enfrentó con intereses inmobiliarios.
Algunos de los principales constructores de la ciudad
están construyendo más de 1,5 millones de m2
en Hudson Yards.
Y vinieron a proponerme "desmontar temporalmente"
esa tercera y última parte.
Quizás High Line no encajaba
en su idea de una ciudad brillante de rascacielos sobre una colina.
Quizás solo les entorpecía el camino.
Como fuera, llevó 9 meses de continuas negociaciones diarias
para conseguir que se firmara el acuerdo que prohíbe su demolición,
y eso fue hace solo 2 años.
Así que ya ven, no importa cuán popular o exitoso sea un espacio público:
nunca se lo puede dar por seguro.
Los lugares públicos --esta es la parte rescatada--
siempre necesitan defensores atentos,
no solo para reclamarlos para el uso público,
sino para diseñarlos para la gente que los usa,
luego para mantenerlos, para garantizar que sean para todos,
que no sean violados, invadidos, abandonados o ignorados.
Si algo he aprendido en mi carrera como planificadora urbana,
es que los lugares públicos tienen poder.
No solo por el número de personas que los usan,
sino por el número aún mayor de personas
que se sienten mejor con su ciudad simplemente por saber que están ahí.
Los espacios públicos pueden cambiar cómo vives en una ciudad,
lo que sientes por esa ciudad, si la prefieres a alguna otra.
Son una de las principales razones por las que te quedas en esa ciudad.
Yo creo que una buena ciudad es como una fiesta fabulosa.
La gente se queda porque la está pasando bien.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)